*Intro Playing*
-Subtitles by iiceeyArtworks-
Hello Psych2Go-ers!
We just wanna take the time to thank you for all your kind support!
We are a team of dedicated, passionate and hard working individuals
Who come together every day with one goal in mind
We want to make psychology come alive for you!
Many of us want to be in happy, and meaningful relationships,
But nowadays, in a dating scene plagued with superficiality
and an abundance of choice.
making a relationship long term, while staying sane
is much easier said. Than done.
The initial spark is great! But it takes alot more than attraction to sustain a relationship...
What are some ways we can keep a healthy relationship?
and ensure long happiness with our partners? you may ask
Here are 12 signs you're in a healthy relationship!
1. You communicate openly
A great relationship starts with transparency
Do you feel like you could communicate about anything with your partner?
From personal needs to taboo topics?
Do the both of you take the time to listen and empathize with each other?
Good communication means using a sort of techniques,
Which includes: welcoming body language, concentrated listening, and respectful language
2. You argue
This might sound strange, but arguing sometimes is actually healthy in a relationship
Otherwise, you're probably just bottling up your feelings and letting them turn into resentment
Couples who communicate well can argue affectively,
Both parties can state their opinions whilst trying to understand where the other person is coming from
The also know when to apologize if they are wrong
This point, however shouldn't be confused with destructive fighting.
In which couples use aggressive behavior and language to hurt each other when they disagree about an issue
3. You keep relationship details private
It's normal to turn to close friends and family for relationship advice when you run into conflict with your partner.
But making your problems public, on social media is 'passive aggressive'
and can damage the trust you've built with them...
Everyone needs a sense of privacy to feel safe, including relationships!
4. You don't hold grudges.
The more you get to know your partner, The more you may get on each other's nerves, which is normal
We all get a little agitated from time to time, and say and do things we don't mean that can upset our partner
But, holding a grudge. Even after they apologize sincerely
Can hurt your relationship in the long run,
Be sure to talk things out instead, when you're upset. and learn to let go.
5. You have realistic expectations
The 'perfect partner' doesn't exist. It takes a lot of work to keep a relationship going!
Healthy couples understand, that the key to a long-lasting relationship is commitment.
open - communication, and compromise
6. You take time, and space for yourself
Being in a healthy relationship. Doesn't mean you're glued at the hip!
It means you can have seperate lives, interests and friends.
and maintain your own sense of individuality.
Without fearing that your partner is going to be jealous, or resentful
Having a life outside of a relationship is essential!
7. You trust each other
Healthy couples can spend time away from each other, without worrying about their whereabouts, or who they're with
Stalking a partner on social media, and asking them for constant updates however. Are signs of trust issues or co-dependancy
Trust, means respecting your partners decisions, and feeling secure
8. You enjoy spending time together
Whether that means dinner dates, or cuddling on the couch. You enjoy spending time with your partner no matter what!
A healthy relationship involves taking time out of your busy schedule to connect with your partner
It's not just an obligation, But a way for you to enjoy your life
9. You're friends!
Great couples share common interests, enjoy hanging out together and making each other laugh
Just like best friends, healthy couples can talk about *anything*
and confide in each other without fear of judgement.
It's important to feel comfortable with your partner
10. You make decisions together
Healthy relationships, aren't a power stuggle.
They are a partnership that allows both individuals, to have equal say
If you disagree on which restaurant to go to for your date,
One of you may have to give in, but next weekend. The choice should be yours
Compromise is key
11. You get intimate
Yes, ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) is extremely beneficial in healthy relationships. But so is intamacy
Intimacy can be bonding. Sexually, or otherwise (Jesus you where pg a minute ago)
Familiarality or romance.
Maintaining a healthy relationship, means hording your partner with affection
Quality time, Gift giving, or other forms of love language
12. YAY FINALLY, MY ARMS ACHE
12. You make each other better
Fixing, Is not the same as supporting.
Healthy relationships consist of couples, that love one another for who they are.
Not who they *want* them to be
Are their items on this list that you and your partner practice regularly?
Let us know in the comments below!
*Gracious outro music*
SUBSCRIBE TO PSYCHO2GO THEY HELPED ME!
bYE hOOmANS